devant la pyramide du loup créé voulue
par françois mitterrand
avec évidemment le louvre rappelons que
c'était de l'ancien siège du ministère
des finances ont modéré giscard
d'estaing avait d'ailleurs ses bureaux
brest un lieu évidemment d'armes et
stecher a réussi un lieu politique
l'action c'est mieux
hollande qui sera son premier ministre
devait déjà il s'empêtre système et les
manuels mais à l'écouter puisqu'il va
c'est quand il s'exprime et on essaiera
de répondre à cette question sur le
premier ministre évidemment que tout est
sûre importante
[Applaudissements]
merci mes amis merci à vous d'être là ce
soir
vous êtes des dizaines de milliers et je
ne vois que quelques visages
merci merci d'être là de vous êtes
battus avec courage et bienveillance
pendant tant de moi parce que oui ce
soir
vous l'avez emporté la france l'un
portait
ce que nous avons fait depuis tant et
tant de mois
nani précédent ni équivalent tout le
monde nous disait que c'était impossible
mais il ne connaissait pas la france
merci de votre confiance
merci du temps que vous avez donnée
merci de votre engagement à toutes et
tous merci des risques pris par certains
je laissais cette confiance elle
m'oblige et j'en suis désormais le
dépositaire ne pas vous décevoir être à
la hauteur de celle ci est portée durant
les cinq années qui viennent les
lentilles et le vôtre l'élan que vous
représentez je veux aussi ce soir avoir
un mot pour les français qui ont voté
pour moi sans avoir nos idées vous vous
êtes engagé et je sais qu'il ne s'agit
pas là d'un blanc seing
je veux avoir un mot pour les français
qui ont voté simplement pour défendre la
république face à l'extrémisme
je sais nos désaccords
je les respecterai mais je serai fidèle
à cet engagement pris je protègerai la
république
et je veux enfin avoir un mot pour ceux
qui ont voté aujourd'hui pour madame le
pen n'est sifflé pas ils ont exprimé
ils ont exprimé aujourd'hui une colère
un désarroi parfois des convictions je
les respecte mais je ferai tout durant
les cinq années qui viennent pour qu'il
n'ait plus aucune raison de voter pour
les extrêmes
ce soir il n'y a que les françaises et
les français
le peuple de france réunis est ce que
vous représentez ce soir ici au louvre
c'est une ferveur un enthousiasme c'est
l'énergie du peuple de france
et ce lieu dans lequel nous nous
retrouvons dit cela il est parcouru par
notre histoire de l'ancien régime à la
libération de paris de la révolution
française à l'audace de cette pyramide
c'est le lieu de tous les français de
toutes les france de toutes les
françaises
ce lieu c'est celui de la france que le
monde regarde
car ce soir c'est l'europe c'est le
monde qui nous regardent
l'europe le monde attendent que nous
défendions partout l'esprit des lumières
menacés dans tant d'endroits ils
attendent que partout nous défendions
les libertés que nous protégions les
opprimés ils attendent que nous portions
une nouvelle espérance un nouvel
humanisme celui d'un monde plus sûr d'un
nom de liberté défendu d'un nom de
croissance de plus de justice
de plus d'écologie ils attendent que
nous soyons en ce1 nous
[Applaudissements]
la tâche qui nous attend mes chers
concitoyens est immense et elle
commencera dès demain elle imposera de
moraliser la vie publique de défendre
notre vitalité démocratique de renforcer
notre économie de construire les
nouvelles protections le ce monde qui
nous entoure de donner une place à
chacun par l'école et le travail et la
culture de refonder notre europe et
d'assurer la sécurité de tous les
français
cette tâche qui nous attend est immense
et elle imposera de continuer à être
audacieux
oui ce soir nous avons gagné un droit un
droit qui nous oblige vous avez choisi
le das et cette audace lui la tour
suivant et chaque jour qui vient nous
continuerons à la portée parce que c'est
ce que les françaises et les français
attendent parce que c'est ce que
l'europe et le monde attend de nous
ils attendent qu'un nouveau la france
les étonne que la france soit elle-même
et c'est cela ce que nous ferons
notre tâche est immense mais amy elle
exigera l'engagement de chacun
l'engagement de nos armées de nos forces
de l'ordre de tous nos services publics
votre engagement chacune et chacun
élus associations dirigeants syndicats
salariés fonctionnaires commerçants
artisans agriculteurs
étudiants retraités notre tâche est
immense et elle imposera l'exigence de
la vérité le courage de la vérité celui
que durant cette campagne nous avons
constamment porté et que je continuerai
de portée pour vous notre tâche est
immense elle imposera de construire dès
demain une majorité vrai une majorité
forte
cette majorité de changement
c'est ce à quoi le pays aspire et c'est
ce qu'il mérite cette majorité de
changement
c'est cela ce que j'attends de vous dans
six semaines
car j'aurai encore et encore besoin de
vous
[Applaudissements]
mes chers concitoyens vous toutes et
tous qui êtes là à mes côtés depuis tant
et tant de jours tant et tant de nuits
peuple de france ici rassemblés au
louvre nous avons la force nous avons
l'énergie
nous avons la volonté celle qui nous a
portés tu as fait ce que nous sommes
c'est cela ce qui conduira notre avenir
nous ne céderons rien à la peur nous ne
céderons rien à la division nous ne
céderons rien au mensonge
nous ne céderons même rien à l'ironie à
lens reçoit à l'amour du déclin ou de la
défaite je sais cette ferveur que vous
portez je sais ce que je vous dois je
sais ce soir ce que je dois à mes
compagnons de route à mes amis à ma
famille et à mes proches
[Applaudissements]
ce ne sera pas tous les jours facile je
le sais la tâche sera dure
je vous dirai à chaque fois la vérité
mais votre serveur votre énergie votre
courage toujours me porteront je vous
proposerai face aux menaces
je combattrai pour vous contre le
mensonge l'immobilisme l'inefficacité
pour améliorer la vie de chacun
je respecterai chacune et chacun dans ce
qu'ils pensent et dans ce qu'il défend
je rassemblerai et je ré concilierait
car je veux l'unité de notre peuple et
de notre pays et enfin mes amis je vous
servirai je vous servirai avec humilité
avec force je vous servirait au nom de
notre devise liberté égalité fraternité
je vous servirai dans la fidélité de la
confiance que vous m'avez donné je vous
servirai avec amour vive la république
vive la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean-baptiste lemoyne le mise en scène
discours mise en scène soignée